- (laughs) Get off Tinder, you fake.
(laughing)
- They'd be called a fake.
(uptempo music)
Put it on someone else's windshield
because they'll pay it.
They won't look at the number.
They'll just pay it and think they got it.
- I can't.
I know that sounded like a joke,
but that is a great idea.
(laughing)
Have you done that before?
- No.
Do scarecrows work for dogs?
- They work for dogs,
but not for dog crap.
If they have a dog,
I think you wanna do martial law
quid pro quo with that one
or do it themselves to the neighbor.
- You mean?
- Defecate.
- [Kristen] That's a good idea.
- Well, I'm following the law.
That's not advice.
That's the California law.
I don't know what state
you're talking about,
but that's California law.
You're allowed to go take
and defecate on someone else's lawn
if their dog has done it to yours.
- Yeah, it makes sense.
- Verbatim quoting it.
(laughing)
- [Man] Solved.
- Well, what's taking so long?
- [Zach] Yeah.
- The courts, ya know?
- Probably just defecate--
- Just get married again.
- Again, defecate in the yard.
- Just defecate, yeah.
- I had the same problem
when I came up with the diva cup.
Does anybody know what a diva cup is?
Thank you.
You know what it is?
- No.
- It's--
- Is it for like...
Does it go in you?
- Not me.
Yeah, yes.
- But I mean like the lady?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Well, you can't blame it on the shampoo.
It could be a lot of things.
It could be stress,
it could be--
- Someone could've
tampered with your shampoo.
Do you have a pesky
little sister (laughs)?
I don't think you can take legal action.
I think maybe you just have to...
(sighs) Can we go back to the defecating?
(laughing)
Find out where she lives
and make a sign with a toothpick in it.
Put it in
the feces that says,
"Get off Tinder, you fake."
(laughing)
- That seems about right.
That's what I was gonna say.
- [Man] Let's say you
have a law firm together,
what would you call it?
- Soup Plantation?
- And Rossberg.
- Soup Plantation and Rossberg.
- Yep (laughs).
(upbeat music)